[Music]
foreign watching The Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what's making the
headlines with the columnist Carol
Malone and the political editor of the
Liverpool Echo Liam Thorpe welcome to
both of you so to the headlines the
front pages then let us start with the I
and a new anti-strike laws they say
could make industrial action worse the
government has admitted that is the lead
story for that paper Financial Times
leading with this story hunt loosens
Financial Services rules to free City
potential as a growth driver Iranian
forces are shooting at the faces and
genitals of female protesters reads the
front of the Guardian as they look at
how women are strategically targeted at
anti-regime protests in Iran the Metro
leads with Prince Harry's comments made
in the couple's much anticipated Netflix
documentary released today that the
Royals don't marry for Love The Daily
Star reports that the sussex's Netflix
documentary cost 90 million pounds to
make tele Express looks at the rail
which has emerged over whether the
Royals were given a right of reply to
Harry and Megan's claims and the Daily
Mail leads with the same story the
headline Palace anger and assault on the
Queen's Legacy
Palace and Netflix Clash over sussex's
soap opera that is the front of the
times and this story on the front of the
daily telegraphics headline sussex's TV
show claims are a direct hit on the late
Queen's Legacy
finally stop this Royal circus reads the
front of the Daily Mirror well reminded
by scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's
newspapers while you watch us our guests
and facts so let us go back to Carol
Malone and Liam fall welcome to both of
you
um Carol I think you are one of those
who sat through the three episodes today
don't don't roll your eyes already
anyway plenty of newspaper coverage
um we'll probably get to the guardian
but I see they've given it in a proper
review
um three stars out of five what's your
verdict
actually I love the stars from page was
actually said that homes under the
hammer was more interesting and the
viewers liked it better but anyway I
think do you know I got up at eight
o'clock to watch it and I was actually
quite excited at the thought of it
um and and when I got through the first
one uh which was so syrupy and sacrony
and it had all the normal grapes and
moans and groans you know if it happened
eight o'clock I'd have a drink to get
through the next one it was so it was so
boring you know I mean it was the ROMs
might not think it's boring because they
came in for a bit of criticism but you
know no no more than they have in recent
in the recent past yes they they had a
go at uh Kate
um
saying she was cold yes they had a go
with Charles and they had a dig at him
and Harry actually said a bizarre thing
that he was brought up by a family in
Africa which is like crazy he was there
for a couple of months a year
um but you know it was that all the
normal whinging and moaning and and they
laid bare their love story friend of
mine who watched it said it was like you
know when you when you meet up with a
friend and they say should we look at my
holiday photos and your hard things it
was like that watching the story of
their love because of course they picked
all the most beautiful pictures of Megan
and all the all the best pictures of
them together making them look like this
perfect couple
um and it was just dull it was it was
like I don't know whether anybody's
watching watches those there's a studio
in America called Hallmark and it makes
all these mushy movies and this I'm sure
the script writers that write the
Hallmark films wrote the script for
Harry and Megan because it was just it
was soppy it was happy it was cringy and
and I just I think Netflix must be
actually thinking they bought a dud here
and I mean I don't know what the next
three are gonna contain but certainly
the first three were a little bit on the
boring side the fact that I would think
the royal family are delighted although
they're saying they're hurt and upset I
think they're probably delighted they
were probably expecting much much worse
as were we and talking about the media
we came in for the biggest pasting of
all
um I mean Harry's anger about us is
still raw and vicious and and you know
he just hates us
um and Netflix the interesting the
interesting thing was Netflix had lots
of stories about Paparazzi
um chasing Megan and you know it turns
out that none of the paparazzi we're
chasing Megan or from this country that
were from the US or Canada but so
Netflix has actually misrepresenting the
story in their way they were pulled up
for doing that in their trailer by using
footage that had nothing to do with the
paparazzi following Harry and Megan and
they've done it again actually in the
documentary so there are lots of
misrepresentations in there already and
over the next 24 hours I'm sure that the
British tabloids that Harry hates so
much will come up with lots more of them
well let's take a look at some of the
the Tabloid coverage shall we for
example
um The Daily Mirror stop this Royal
circus uh just two months after our
queen died Prince Harry is bemoaning his
treatment again Prince William is
venting his fear again meanwhile
thousands of ordinary Brits are choosing
between eating and heating there was
certainly a bit of a now gilded not
caged uh you know California and
sunshine type existence that they now
live in but
um I didn't find it quite as saccharine
as you and there's absolutely nothing
wrong with those Hallmark style films
I'm quite obsessed with their the
Christmas offerings
there's a lot of misery around right now
but anyway for me a lot of this was wow
this is this is this is a matter of
historical record now you know from the
horse's mouth for example you know who
was the friend who introduced them they
met on Instagram via Instagram you know
they'd only met twice and he whispered
off to Botswana sort of clarifying some
of the things we kind of knew about at
the time Liam but but but this is this
is you know the holiday snap thing mix
it is bigger than somebody else's
holiday snap so for me it kind of lays
down history at least their version of
what do you think Liam
yeah I'm finding it hard to get too
exercised about this if I'm perfectly
honest um I I must admit I haven't seen
it and personally I'm already home
already probably I've probably not seen
any Hallmark films either I'm dreading
the Relentless media coverage that we're
going to see over the next few days I
know people get very very excited about
it I I the front page I agree most with
is the Daily Mirror and I don't mean to
get too Pious about it but I just think
there are so many more important things
going on in people's lives you know I've
been out today speaking to people
sleeping rough on the streets I've been
to warm Banks speaking people who can't
put the heating on you know people
aren't going through massive massive
problems in this country and it just I'm
just sort of dismayed by by how much
coverage this is going to continue to
get for the for the coming days I
understand you know as a journalist it's
a it's a big story but these are all
people of immense privilege whichever
side you come down on these are all
people of immense privilege who who are
despite their various difficulties and
I'm not suggesting some people haven't
had difficulties aren't going through
the same kinds of things that people are
right now across the couldn't see who
you know who you can't afford to put
food on the table so it's it's not
something that massively interests me I
think I did I did find the I did find
the review um Lucy Mangan and the
guardian quite interesting which she
said is what I kind of predicted would
be the case is that when you come to the
end of it nothing really changes
everyone has their entrenched position
and I don't think anyone's going to
change it and whatever your position is
you'll find more strength in that
position in different aspects of this
documentary I don't think anyone's going
to get their minds Changed by other
can I say one thing is that the one
thing that enraged me in it was the
portrayal of Britain as This Racist
cesspit Netflix I'm not saying Harry and
Megan did but Harry Megan did accuse
Britain are being racist and Britain's
have been racist it was kind of the
reason they left but Netflix painted
this country they brought brexit into it
they said brexit and immigration was why
the British public turned on Megan that
was not not why the British mother
turned on Megan when she came to this
country they adored her they turned on
her in the end because she accused them
of being racist when they weren't they
welcomed her with open arms but Netflix
made this country look like we were
still living in the Enoch Powell era
when black people in this country lived
in fear of the hate mongering he was
spreading that is not this country
anymore and it's hideous for Netflix to
suggest it it's also hideous of Harry
and Megan to suggest that the British
people are racist yes and that's the
front page of the Daily Telegraph isn't
it um a deeply offensive Netflix series
Brands the commonwealthers Empire 2.0
um you know using that I think it was
the third I didn't get as far as the
third the third of these documentaries
um you'd probably tell me if it was but
anyways a lot of that so so the use of
Empire
um you know races as a central theme but
also the Diana Legacy and Harry watching
his mother go through what he called
being swarmed formed by Paparazzi that
was his childhood memory being swarmed
was the word he used Carol you want to
pick up
he tried oh sorry gone go for it yeah
yeah yeah you started he tried to
compare what happened to Diana and say
that was the same of hack to Megan that
is simply not true when Megan was in
this country she was and she was with
Harry formally she was always protected
by security she was not swarmed by
Paparazzi and it's interesting to say
that all the shots that they showed him
Paparazzi swarming her were not in this
country they were in the US and they
were in Canada so that was that was very
naughty of them to do that but I you
know I don't think the British public
are going to be fooled by this for a
single second I don't think that they're
going to be fooled by the the mushiness
of it the toe curling mushiness of of
what their what they were saying but I
think they will be furious about being
the but this country and the British
people have been slated as racist by
these two it's it's appalling yes let's
let's take a look at the Daily Mail
because I know you know mail online has
a deep Fascination you know
um they've been court cases with the
sister to paper and so on but between
them anyway
um it's as if they want to bring down
the monarchy say insiders this is their
front page story a lot to the side as
you can see from the the banner headline
up there but do you get a sense that
um you know people have said the
business model is to trash the royal
family the once this is all out they can
start hopefully moving on to those good
causes that they are so passionate about
Liam I mean Carol's already laughing but
you know like Africa we know Africa for
uh for Harry was a major passion of his
and women's rights for for Megan get
this all out the way set the record
straight and then they can move on is
that is that should we all hope for that
that's for sure look I think it's
possible to think two things you know
from from my sort of very sort of
limited opinion on this I think it's
it's fair it's it's possible to think
that that um Megan and Harry have
endured a lot of difficulties and that
and that they have you know we heard the
former head of the National Crime agency
saying about the the regular threats
made against Megan's life now I think
it's perfectly reasonable to to to think
that um that there is some elements of
racism too that I don't think that I
think we've seen some some evidence of
some racist threats made again so now
that doesn't necessarily mean as Carol
says that the whole country is racist I
think there are there are issues that we
need to confront in this country but
it's also possible to think that perhaps
this doing this massive Netflix drama
what documentary sorry wasn't wasn't the
best idea in terms of being able to kind
of move on and and live in that that
life that you know that they want to
live which is obviously a bit they've
said would be more out of the line like
I don't think that I'm not sure the two
things kind of work together as I say I
would prefer if everybody could move on
from this and focus on some some more
real issues but I think it's possible to
feel sympathy for these people because
they've clearly gone through a lot yes
and this is the idea yeah
is silly because as long as companies
like Netflix are playing the
multi-million pounds to trash the Royal
farming they will continue to do it
there is nothing stopping them doing
their charity work in Africa now they
could be focusing on that instead
they're focusing on making millions by
trashing the royal family but but then
you make the millions and then you start
doing the courses that was kind of my
point you know you get yourself
comfortable no no they won't get why
wouldn't they're not going to give it up
this is their career now this is what
they do you know she received an award
this week for for outing racism in the
royal family that can consisted of her
telling Oprah Winfrey that a
conversation about Harry's skin color
happened this was a
was aberrated conversation the royal
family denied that it ever happened but
she's been able to to be this
of racism because of a conversation she
says happened and that the royal family
said didn't this is where we're at with
her they want to make money and that
they will they will do what they do for
as long as they can to me as long as the
money is there well the Daily Mail
paragraph I'm going to read out is the
Duchess of Sussex described them as an
account of the couple's love story but
critics said they were a Sly and
Insidious assault on Harry's family and
the institution of the crown and there
were calls last night for the sussexes
to give up their titles if they were so
ashamed and disappointed about their
links to the royal family so should they
lose their Royal titles Carol
absolutely in fact they shouldn't be
asked to give them up there should be
strips of them why should they be
allowed to monetize these titles which
is exactly what they were doing if they
were just playing Megan and Harry
companies like Netflix would not be
throwing Millions at them
become a sad couple retelling the same
old tired stories which actually is what
this Docker already is but as long as
they're the Duke and Duchess of Suffolk
they have traction and and of course
Charles should take them away nor should
he give Archie the title of Prince which
which Archie is entitled to now because
Charles is now King something that Megan
said in the documentary that he had been
denied it wasn't the case the title of
Prince could only ever be conferred on
Archie when Charles became king but he
shouldn't give them that either if as
the male says that you know they're so
ashamed of their Royal links and the
royal family why would they want to be
still be associated with it so I've just
seen the time chatting too much um just
want to show the times as well you know
some beautiful pictures of them uh all
credited I see to the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex and Netflix so uh you know
there's a lot of pictures been taken and
lots of information for the newspapers
to chew over
um in those three uh documentaries that
we've had released so far more next week
of course anyway plenty more still to
come this story on the front page of the
Guardian the headlines suspended
sentence for the killer of Harry Dunn
discussing that thanks as well
[Music]
well welcome out you're watching the
Press preview with me once again
columnist Carol Malone and the political
editor of the Liverpool Echo Liam Thorpe
welcome to you
um strikes we've been talking about them
for weeks it feels now Liam
um are anti-strike laws planned by the
government because the eye is suggesting
that if they're brought in it could make
matters worse talk us through it
yeah so it seems like the government's
current only plan for dealing with the
strikes with the unions is to try and
make it harder to strike which which I
think is an absolute disgrace I think
it's a fundamental right for workers to
be able to unionize to be able to strike
to be able to fight for better deals
we've seen that work we've seen that
happen over time that's the reason why
we've got things like paid uh paternity
maternity leave why we've got paid sick
leave things like that obviously the the
government are not prepared to get back
around the table with some some of the
unions so this is this is where is your
next answer it's something that Liz
trust kind of started but as the eye
have reported here which is quite sort
of ironic really um this report by Hugo
G Paul war and our thing is that
actually these these anti-strike laws
which will be about maintaining a
minimum level of service when strikes
are going on in certain industries and
other areas could actually result in
more strikes happening and that is not
just hyperbole that is from the
government's own risk assessments into
its own policy which basically says it
could encourage more people to go on
strike like it could encourage the
unions to take firmer and harder action
and actually create more disruption if
we take the trains for example you know
Mick Lynch is not someone who looks like
he's going to be backing down anytime
soon so even when the government have
tried to find a way to kind of crush the
the spirit of the unions it it doesn't
look like it's going to work and I think
most people could agree the best thing
to do is for them to get back around the
table and meaningfully negotiate which
the unions are certainly saying that
isn't happening right now apologies for
rushing you we've run out of time Carol
you were frowning again we'll talk we'll
we'll hear all your thoughts on that a
little bit later on for now thank you
very much indeed uh we will see you
later Liam and Carol about later now
though